[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN WEBER: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Ryan Weber, Project
Manager of Google Sheets.
And today, I'll be talking
about Google Sheets
and giving you some tips and
tricks to boost productivity.
You can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
So with that, let's get started.
All right.
So today, we'll be
covering tips to boost
productivity that will span the
typical analytical workflow.
Now, the first stage in
this analytical workflow
is the collect phase.
This is to get data from
wherever it may live and bring
it right into your spreadsheets.
Next, we have the prepare flow.
This is where you the
data in your Sheets
and you clean it and get
it ready for analysis.
And for the next flow, the
analyze and visualize stage.
Now, in this stage,
you're taking the data
and you're actually
generating those insights
and those learnings to
help figure out and make
sense of that data.
Finally, we have
the share phase.
This is where you're
sharing out your data
in your spreadsheet
in order to get,
either your collaborators in
the spreadsheet to help you,
or to share with end
recipients who will be viewing
and consuming that content.
Now, all of this is on top
of real-time collaboration.
This is at the heart of not only
Sheets, but of G Suite itself.
And we'll go into a bit more
about how to get the most out
of the collaboration.
So that's the order of
topics we'll be going through
in today's talk.
And we'll end it with
talking about how Sheets
is ready for
Enterprise so you can
get the most of spreadsheets
in your company.
So with that, let's dive in.
Let's talk about getting
data into your spreadsheet.
So first, let's talk
about templates.
So templates have
been added to Sheets.
We have dozens of
professionally-designed
templates to choose from.
They cover a wide
variety of use cases.
And rather than
starting from scratch,
you can open up a
template and start
entering data using an
already crafted template.
Additionally, you can create
your own domain templates.
These are templates
that are specific
to your particular company.
Let's say, for example,
that your finance team
has a particular way they like
to report out every month.
Rather than recreating
that report every month
from scratch, you can create
a template once, save it
to the Template Gallery.
And that way,
within your company,
that domain template
is available for you
with all the themes,
colors, font, et cetera,
that your company uses
already in the spreadsheet.
Next, you can get data into your
spreadsheets by importing it.
Let's say someone
sends you a file.
It could be many
different types of files.
We have support for CSV,
for example, Comma Separated
Value files, in Excel.
And right from Gmail, there
will be an attachment card
like you see on the screen.
And you would simply
click the Pencil icon.
It will open up that
file into Sheets.
And you can edit
right within Sheets
with one click-- very simple.
You also can get data into
Sheets by import functions.
So we have a whole host
of import functions
that you can use when you're
writing your formulas,
things that will pull
in data from externally
saved files, from RSS feeds,
from web pages, from XML.
But the one that's
used the most often
is the first one, the
Importrange function.
This allows you to pull in
data from other spreadsheets.
So you can write a formula
that has an import range, put
in the URL of the other formula,
and that will pull in data
from another spreadsheet.
It's an easy way to link
spreadsheets and pull
in data from other sources.
So I would encourage
you to check that out.
You don't have to remember all
the information on this slide.
If you just start typing
equal and start typing import,
you'll see autocomplete
will show up along
with some information that
will help you learn a bit more
about these functions.
Google Forms is another
really popular way
to get data into Sheets.
So with Google
Forms, you can simply
create a series of questions
of all different types.
You set up the form.
You can send it out
to a bunch of people
from whom you want to
collect that information.
And as they fill
it out and submit,
that data will flow
right into Sheets
where you can do
further analysis,
you can create your charts,
your pivot tables and all that
on that data--
very simple.
Next, you can get data
into Sheets via our API.
So APIs allow third parties
to integrate with Sheets.
So you can get data both from
Sheets into third party sources
as well as from third party
sources right into Sheets.
And we worked hard
to continue to update
the API to support all the
functionality in Sheets.
As we add new features,
we're continually
adding more capabilities
into the API.
One thing we've
added in last year
is called Developer metadata.
What that allows
developers to do
is to stay on top of how
users interact with Sheets.
So you have data within a sheet
that's linked to a CRM system,
for example.
And the users in the
sheet are rearranging
columns, or renaming
things, or changing rows.
The metadata allows developers
to stay on top of those changes
so that everything
is still in sync.
So that's a pretty
powerful feature.
Next, we're excited to
talk about SAP to Sheets.
This is a new feature that
launched in the last year.
Now we have seamless export
from SAP into Sheets.
Now we know a lot of
companies live on SAP.
All the operations
they have stored there
is very critical for business.
And so now with--
very simple, you can export
from SAP right into Sheets,
open up the file in Sheets,
and see all the data,
and do simple
analysis in Sheets.
If you want to check
out more about this,
you can go to the link
on the screen there,
cloud.google.com/sap/sap
and gsuite.
We're also excited to
announce the Sheets data
connectors for BigQuery.
Now, this is actually
something that we just
announced a month ago at our
Google Cloud Next conference.
This is available
today in a beta.
And what this
allows you to do is
connect to BigQuery and to
pull in data from BigQuery
right into Sheets.
So you can write a simple
SQL query in Sheets.
So if you see on
the screen there,
you can pick your
billing project.
You hit write query.
You can enter in some SQL.
And then, when you run your
SQL, if you hit Insert Results,
it'll now run that
query, pull the data,
and pop it into Sheets.
What that does now is, if
you want to refresh the data,
all you need to do is
hit the Refresh button,
and it will refresh the
data for you automatically.
Then they can share with
their collaborators.
They also can refresh that
data if they have access
to the underlying data source.
No need for them to write
additional SQL queries.
It's very simple to
have that connection.
If you're interested in trying
out this feature in limited
beta, go to that
link on the screen,
gsuite.google.com/bq-sheets,
and sign up for the beta.
I'm also excited to talk about
a data connector to Salesforce.
So with Salesforce,
we now have an add-on
that was created by Google
Cloud in beta program.
You can now pull in data
from Salesforce into Sheets,
and you also can push
changes from Sheets
back into Salesforce.
So for those of you who
are interested in that,
please check that out.
All right.
That's a few different ways
to get data from wherever
it may live into Sheets.
Now, let's talk about
transforming that data
and getting it
ready for analysis.
So in order to prep
your data, there's
a few things you can do.
First, we have Text to columns.
So if you have
data that you want
to turn into a table
of columns, you
can use Text to columns feature.
We've had support for that for
a while on things like comma
separating values,
tabs, et cetera.
So that's all been
there for a while.
You can use that today.
And we've also added
support for what's
called fixed-width formatting.
So the file on the
screen on the left
is an example of
fixed-width formatted file.
And if you import it now
using Text to columns,
it will automatically be
turned into the tabular
data on the right.
So again, Text to columns is
how you can transform raw data
into a table of data.
If you're preparing
your data for analysis,
you also might want to be
expanding and collapsing
rows and columns.
This is a common Enterprise
request we've had.
And we've added it in the
last couple of months.
So now you can easily collapse
and expand columns and rows
with ease by using
this Grouping feature.
We've also introduced
Checkboxes into Sheets.
So what Checkboxes
will allow you to do
is, if you have a column,
and in that column
you have two values--
true/false, yes/no,
reviewed/unreviewed--
whatever it might be--
you can transform it
into a checkbox, where
one value will be checked, and
one value will be unchecked.
Then you can treat the checkbox
like any other value in Sheets.
So if you want to use it
in a formula, you can.
If you want a filter
on it, you can.
You can use
conditional formatting.
The underlying values
are still there.
But it just looks
like a checkbox,
which we've found users
are really excited about.
We've also introduced macros.
This is a huge
productivity booster.
It can save you a lot of time
by automating repetitive work.
And so what macros are
doing is, you hit Record,
and you can do a bunch of
stuff in Sheets, whether it's
formatting data, creating
a chart, whatever you
might be doing,
you are recording
that using the Macro Recorder.
And then, when you
hit Save, it will
remember everything you did.
So then you can go back
and replay that macro,
and it will repeat
all the steps for you.
That way, it'll save you time.
It will prevent you
from missing a step when
you need to repeat it.
So it's a big
productivity booster.
I definitely encourage you
to check that out as well.
Sheets also has what
are called Add-ons.
So add-ons are a way to add
additional functionality
into Sheets.
So when it comes
to data prep, there
are a bunch of
add-ons that you can
use to enhance your Sheets--
things like removing
duplicates, merging
data add-ons,
normalizing values, detecting
outliers, et cetera.
And so all that, again,
will enhance your Sheets
if you add it into
your spreadsheet.
There's also add-ons
of other types outside
of data prep-- so things like
Mail [? Merge, ?] et cetera.
But if you're interested
in supercharging
your spreadsheets, definitely
check out the Add-ons store
and find some great
add-ons that you can use.
Next, I'm going to talk
about Google Apps Script.
So Google Apps
Script-- what is it?
It's a scripting language
in the Google Apps platform.
What can it do?
It can do a bunch of stuff.
One, you can create automation.
So when you are
actually recording
a macro, what it's doing
underneath the covers
is actually writing those
steps in Apps Script.
You also can manually
do that as well
if you want to get
more complex than what
you're trying to automate.
So you can create those
automations with Apps Script.
You also can write
custom functions.
So Sheets gives you over 400
functions out of the box.
But let's say you
have a new function
that you've come up with.
You can create it
using Apps Script
and then use it like any other
function within your formulas
in your spreadsheets.
And finally, you can use
Apps Script with triggers.
So triggers are when there's
actions that happen in Sheets.
So when someone opens
a file, when someone
makes an edit to a file-- all
those are triggers that then
can kick off some
of the automations
you created in Apps Script.
So that's another powerful
way to enhance what's
possible in your spreadsheet.
So with Apps Scripts-- you
can see that on the right--
it's basically JavaScript with
additional capabilities added
to it.
And we've worked hard to
make it fully featured.
And so this year, we've added
additional functionality
like pivot tables, charts,
the conditional formatting,
among other things,
into Apps Script.
So if you've tried it
before, give it another shot,
and see what's possible now.
So with that, I'm
going to jump in
to show you a demo of how
to use some of this stuff.
So let's take a
look at a file here.
So this file has four tabs.
Each tab is quarterly data.
The data is different
in every tab,
but the columns are
all the same-- so
all the same structure.
So what I like to do is
I like to clean it up.
I like to prepare it just once.
I'll do it on this Q1 tab
and then replay those changes
on subsequent tabs.
So to do that, I can go to
the Tools Menu, go to Macros,
and hit Record Macro.
What this is going to do is,
now you see a blinking red light
at the bottom.
So now, it's listening.
It's recording what
I'm going to do.
So every action I take now,
it will track those actions.
And so what I can
do is if I-- let's
say I want to highlight all of
the data in the spreadsheet.
I can do that.
And I want to resize
it now to fit.
You'll see that, next
to the red light,
it's capturing all of those
actions as I'm recording it.
So let's add some
alternating colors.
We'll change it to green.
Let's be done with that.
And we also can freeze the first
row so that's easy to scroll.
And then there's a bunch
of true and false values
in that column.
Let's see, how about let's
change this to percentage.
And we can fix the
precision to be--
yep, that's better.
And then for the
true and false, we
can actually use
checkboxes, rather
than saying true and false.
So Data Validation--
I'll change this to
Checkbox and hit Save.
And so now that's been changed.
And then finally, these
columns, Start and Finish--
I want to hide those columns
so I can add the new grouping
feature.
Let's group columns G and H,
and I can collapse this now.
So this looks good.
Let's say I'm done with this.
I feel like this is an
adequately prepared sheet.
I will save it.
I'll give it a name.
So here, you can
give it whatever name
you want for easy recall later.
And then I can give it
a keyboard shortcut,
in this case,
Command-Option-shift-1,
and we'll hit Save.
So now it's saving the macro--
Macro Saved-- great.
So now if I go to Q2, this tab--
rather than redoing everything
manually, I can go to the
Macros Menu, find that macro,
and just replay it.
And it will do all those
steps for me instantly.
It helps me prevent
making mistakes,
helps prevent me
from missing a step--
very simple, like magic.
So that's how macros work.
All right.
Moving on to Analyze
and Visualize--
so this is where the
rubber meets the road.
This is where we are
going to discover
all those insights to get
the most out of our data.
So pivot tables are in Sheets.
For those of you
who are unfamiliar,
pivot tables are a way
to summarize your data,
to group and aggregate
data in useful ways.
Sheets has had pivot
tables for a while,
but we worked hard to make
them even better for you
this past year.
So this is the old
pivot table format.
We've actually overhauled them
to look a little nicer like you
see on the screen.
So we think it looks
a little better.
We've added a bunch of
other features as well.
We now have drill downs.
This is the ability
to either double click
or say Show Details
on a particular cell
and see all the
underlying values.
We have groupings.
So you can now group up
arbitrarily on values and also
expand out in different ways.
We have Show Value
as a Percentage--
was a common request, as well
as being able to customize
the text in the headers.
You can also choose whether
or not to repeat row labels.
And again, as I
mentioned before,
we have the Refreshed UI.
So all that has made
pivot tables even better.
So again, I encourage
you to check that out.
It's a great tool
in doing analysis.
Next, I want to talk
about different ways
to filter data in Sheets.
Sheets actually has several
different ways to do this.
So first are what
are called filters.
Now filters change
content for everybody.
So when you filter
down to, let's
say, a particular
value, anyone else
doing that spreadsheet
will see the same thing.
They'll all see
the filtered data.
We also have what are
called Filter views.
Now, Filter views-- when
you filter down to something
using a Filter view, it's only
doing it for you, the viewer.
It only impacts you.
Anyone else in that spreadsheet
will not see the changes.
That's the difference
between that and filters.
Just to really
hit this home, you
should use filters when you
want to purposely change
the view for everybody
viewing the spreadsheet.
If you want to impact
everybody, use filters.
Also, any changes you make while
using filters-- for example,
changing the sorting--
that will impact everybody even
after you removed the filter.
Now filter views,
you should use those
when you don't want to disrupt
others' views of the data.
So again, if you don't
want people to see what
you're doing, use filter views.
You also can save
multiple filter views
in the spreadsheet.
So let's say you have
multiple different ways
of cutting and slicing
and dicing the data.
You can use filter views
to save all of those.
If you want to share a link
to another user with things
already pre-filtered
you can share a link
to a particular filter
view-- another useful way
to use Filter views.
And if someone shares
a sheet with you,
and you don't have edit
access, you actually
can't use filters
because that's going
to change the underlying data.
But you can use filter views,
because filter views allow
even viewers who
don't have edit access
to the filter of the data.
So again, definitely encourage
you to check out filter views
if you haven't.
They're like filters, but
built for collaboration.
Now Sheets has over 400
spreadsheet functions--
some of them listed
on the right there.
We have everything you
can probably think of.
We have all the basics--
VLOOKUP, SUMIF,
MATCH, et cetera.
We've also added a
bunch in the last year--
some of the more complicated
ones you see on the screen
there--
statistical
functions, et cetera.
We've even added
functions that are
unique to Sheets, things
like AVERAGE.WEIGHTED,
so that's a weighted average.
And then we have
a new one called
SORTN, which actually shows you
the top N values in a range.
Let's go a little deeper on
that one just as an example.
So let's say you want to
find the top five values
from some Salesforce data.
So in this case, I want
to find the top five
regions by revenue.
What I can do-- and this is the
results that I'd like to see.
The way to get that is I
can use the SORTN function,
specify the range, and say
I want the top five values.
And voila, you get the
data that you see above.
Now, if I didn't
have this function,
it would be a lot of work
to make this happen, pretty
complicated.
Luckily, SORTN is there--
makes it much simpler for me.
Sheets also has
Formula suggestions.
This is another
productivity booster.
Let's say you're
doing some analysis.
You have some data.
You go below your table
data, and you type Equals.
All of a sudden, you'll
see some suggestions
of different formulas
that you can use.
So Sheets is predicting what
it thinks you will want.
You can choose one of those
rather than typing things out
manually.
We found that Suggestions
have made formal entry
five times faster for
those who are using it.
It helps speed
things up for you,
helps prevent you
from making mistakes.
So if you see those popping
up, hopefully, you're
taking advantage of those and
getting that productivity boost
with formula suggestions.
Next, we'll talk about charts.
Now, no analysis is complete
without some charts.
We, at the Sheets
team love our charts.
We have all the basic
charts that you need.
We have the pie charts,
line charts, scatter plots,
bar charts.
We've also introduced
a new chart this year
called waterfall chart.
You can see that
on the left there.
Waterfall charts allow you
to see incremental changes
between different segments.
We've also introduced
a lot of other features
to charts in the last year--
things like total data labels.
We've added a way to customize
your colors, tight alignment,
moving data labels,
customizing the line styles,
and we've revamped
the chart UI to make
it more user friendly as well.
So again, play
around with charts
and see how to get the most
out of visualizing your data.
Next, I want to
talk about Explore.
So Explore is bringing
intelligence into Sheets.
You can think about it
as almost like having
your own personal analyst
built right into Sheets.
So With Explore, you can ask
natural language questions
about your data, and
it'll give you answers.
Explore will suggest charts.
It can adjust pivot tables.
It can give you formatting
suggestions-- very simple.
So on the bottom right there,
you see the Explore icon.
You click on that.
That will open up
the Explore sidebar.
And you can click on the
alternating color suggestions.
You can ask those natural
language questions very simply.
Again, it's like
having an analyst right
within your spreadsheet.
In the last year,
we've continued
to enhance what's
possible with Explore.
Now, you actually can
use natural language
to ask for charts
and pivot tables.
And even if you don't know
to ask for those questions,
it will actually even
suggest pivot tables to you.
So that's a new
feature that we've also
launched in the last year.
So with that, let's do a demo.
So here, we have
some Salesforce data.
And we can go down
to the Explore icon.
Click on that to open it up.
And we see now, the
Explore side bar is open.
So what I can do is I see a
bunch of suggestions here.
I see some pivot
tables, some scatter
plots, some different charts.
Let's say I want to ask
a question about my data.
I can type in this box here.
So I want the total
revenue by region.
And voila, I have a pivot table.
If I want, I also can view
this as a chart as well.
So I click over here.
There's the chart.
Back to the pivot table.
Now you'll notice that I didn't
even use the word pivot table.
I just said total
revenue by region.
But yet, it knew that
a way to summarize
that is to the pivot table.
So let's now insert
this into your tab.
OK, great.
Now you'll see that I can
expand this out by date.
Let's choose Close date.
And this has added
date as columns for me.
And so I see the
individual days here.
What I want to do is actually
group them by quarter.
So now, it's going to
summarize all those dates
by quarter as my columns
against the regions in the rows.
So I can see all of
my data summarized
by both region and quarter.
I can click around here.
And I notice that
in Q2 Southwest
region is an
unusually high value.
So I want to dig into
that a little bit more.
I'll right click,
go to Show Details.
And now I'm doing a
drill down into the data
underlying that $5 million.
So here, you can see all the
values in Q2 corresponding
to the Southwest region--
so very simple.
So that is how to use both
Explore and Pivot Tables.
So with that, let's jump
into the next section.
This is share and distribute.
So again, the reasons
to do this are either A,
you want to share out
to collaborators so they
can help you refine
your analysis
and get more out of your
data, or B, maybe you
want to share to
your leadership team
or to your managers
to show them all
the great analysis and results
that you found in Sheets.
So let's talk about the first
use case-- collaborating.
So Sheets allows everyone
to edit together seamlessly.
Again, real time collaboration
has been there since day one.
Here, you see a bunch of people
clicking around, interacting,
changing values.
It's very simple to work
together in a spreadsheet.
No more sending
around attachments.
No more worrying about
getting locked out of a file
or being in an out-of-date file.
Everyone's going to get the
right file at the same time.
It's very seamless.
Next, let's say you
wanted to distribute
your files by putting them
into either Slides or Docs.
Well now Google
supports embedding.
So with this, you can embed
both charts and tables
into both slides and docs.
And when you do
that, it actually
stays linked to the
underlying Sheets file.
So the Sheets file remains
the single source of truth.
That way, if later, you change
the data in your spreadsheet,
you can go back to your Slides
and Docs and, with one click,
refresh those charts and tables
very simply rather than getting
out of date or worrying about
showing the wrong analysis.
So again, that's
a very simple way
to keep data up to date all
within the Google Editors.
We've also worked hard to
help you with printing.
We know a lot of you like
to share and distribute
via printing.
And so we've added a bunch of
new features in the last year,
things like custom page breaks,
custom headers and footers,
custom paper sizes, print
preview, custom margins,
and saving print settings.
So all of that is there.
For those of you who like
to print, check that out.
Another huge productivity
booster we find--
and we use all the time here at
Google, in fact-- are Comments.
So Comments are a rich,
discussion-style functionality
built right into Sheets.
You can simply click on
a cell, add a comment.
If you Plus mention
someone-- so you
put a plus sign and
an email address,
or it at sign and
it will autocomplete
your contact's name.
They'll get an email
notification telling them
that they were
mentioned in a sheet.
They click in that email.
It'll bring them
right to the file--
to the right file, to the
right tab, to the right cell--
where they can either
take action on the cell
directly, or they can reply
to the comment itself.
So you can have a threaded
conversation between you
and your collaborators.
It's very useful.
We also have what are
called Action items.
These are a special kind of
comment, where you actually
can assign a particular
cell to someone.
So let's say you need
someone to review a number
or fill out a cell.
Rather than just passively
mentioning them as an FYI,
you can say, hey, Sarah, can
you please take care of this.
And so she'll be assigned that
cell so that it'll get done.
Next, when you're
collaborating with people,
sometimes it's useful to
know who has seen that file.
So we have now
Activity Dashboard--
another new feature in Sheets.
So let's say you share
it out with your team.
It's been a few days,
and you're curious--
OK, well, who has
actually reviewed
it, and who hasn't yet?
Well, the Activity Dashboard--
it'll show you all that.
And then from this
dashboard, you actually
can email the various people
you've collaborated with.
So you can find those who
haven't reviewed it yet
and email them
from this interface
and say, hey,
please take a look.
I need answers to
this by next Tuesday.
So again, if that is a use
case that resonates with you,
check out Activity Dashboard.
Sheets has something
called Version History.
This is very powerful.
All the edits that
are created in Sheets
are saved within Sheets.
And so in Version
History, you can
see who's made changes,
what have they changed,
and when they made
those changes.
So all that is available
to you as an editor
of the spreadsheet.
We also have what are
called Named Versions.
So Named Versions
actually allow you
to save a name,
or multiple names,
to different
important milestones
in your spreadsheet's history.
So let's say you have a
couple of different drafts
you want to mark as
important milestones,
or you have a final
version that was read out
to your leadership review, you
can keep track of all of that.
And you can use this
now to actually create
what's called a
Diff, or see what's
changed between adjacent
important milestones.
That's called Named Versions.
Also check that out.
Sheets also has
Notification rules.
So Notification rules
are useful if you
want to be notified as soon
as there are edits being made.
So let's say you have a
bunch of collaborators,
and you want to
stay on top of when
they're making those edits.
Using Notification
rules, you can
say email me every
time a change is
made, either when the
change happens, or email me
a digest, or a summary,
of all the changes
at the end of the day.
So again, this is a
more proactive way
of staying on top of all those
changes in your spreadsheet.
Now, great.
We've gone through
a lot of features
in the analytical workflow.
We want to talk now
about how Sheets
is helping users get even
more out of their spreadsheets
for business.
So one, Sheets works hard to
keep your data safe and secure.
No longer do you
need to send around
attachments that could
get easily downloaded
or put onto a USB drive.
Everything is in files
that require you just
to authenticate.
In fact, you can also use
two-factor authentication
for even extra added security.
Also recently announced is
Confidential Mode in Gmail
where the text
itself in the email
is locked down and harder to
distribute beyond that email
itself.
It's harder to forward,
copy, or print, et cetera.
So all of that is
working hard to make sure
that your data and your
company's stay safe and secure.
We also have something called
Prevent download, print,
and copy.
So if you are the
owner of a file--
you're the one who
create that file--
you have the ability in
the Advanced Sharing dialog
to check the Disable options
to download, print, and copy
feature.
Now, what that will do is,
for commenters and viewers,
they won't be able to do those
items in that file any longer.
So again, it's a
way to help prevent
accidental leaking
of data, people
accidentally printing
out a very sensitive file
and having it go beyond
where it was intended to go.
You also can set
expirations on Sheets files.
So let's say you
have someone you
want to share with who
only needs limited access
a limited amount of time.
What you can do is you can find
that file, you can go to share,
you can pop in that
person's email address.
And what you can do is
you go to the Advanced
version of dialogue,
and you share with them,
there's a little clock.
If you click on
that clock, you can
choose that you only want to
share with them for seven days.
And you hit Save.
What that's done is that's
now said that for seven days,
they'll have access.
But at the end of
the seventh day,
they'll automatically
lose access to that file.
Again, that prevents
them from having access
to files that are more
sensitive for a longer time
than you intended.
Additionally, we know that
sometimes folks in business
like to travel.
And so when you're
traveling and you're
on a plane with spotty Wi-Fi or
no Wi-Fi at all, don't worry.
Sheets works both
online and offline.
So we've got your back--
will work no matter how good
your Wi-Fi connectivity is.
Speaking of traveling, we
also work across your devices.
Whether you're on your
laptop, tablet, or mobile,
we have a Sheets
experience there
across different devices that
you can stay productive even
on the go.
Finally, we know how
important keyboard shortcuts
are for folks.
And so we've worked
to try and provide
abilities to help transition
to Sheets by making it easier
to mirror some of the
shortcuts in Sheets with those
that you might be used
to in other programs.
So there's now a
switch that will
allow you to override some
of the browser shortcuts
that were originally claimed
by browsers like Chrome
and Firefox to now match
what you might be expecting
the spreadsheet behavior to be.
And so if you are someone who
loves their keyboard shortcuts,
check that out.
All right.
So that was a lot of different
tips and tricks there.
So now I'm going to
do a brief recap.
I won't read through
all these items here.
But going over the
high-level buckets-- again,
we talked about how to
get data into Sheets
and all the different
ways you can do that
through importing from your
Gmail, using Google Forms,
through the APIs, et cetera.
We talked a bit about
Preparing your data.
So again, this is you can
do things like splitting out
your columns using text to
columns, you can use macros,
you can use Apps
Script, et cetera.
In the analyze phase, we talked
about pivot tables, checkboxes,
charts, formulas,
and using Explore
so you can bring
intelligence to your Sheets.
In sharing and
distribution, we talked
about all the ways you can both
share with your collaborators,
as well as using things like
embedding, using notification
rules, and Version
History to really get
the most out of collaboration.
And finally, we
talked a bit about how
Sheets is Enterprise-ready.
So we talked about how
you can take advantage
of using links, expirations,
preventing copy, printing,
download, et cetera, to
really protect your data.
All right, so that concludes
the main part of this talk.
Stay tuned for live Q&A.
We'll be back in a minute.
All right.
Welcome back.
We're now going to do
a couple of questions
so Let's jump over to
questions from the audience.
First question.
"I'm starting to run into
the 2 million cell limit.
Is that Sheets team
planning on raising this?"
I've got good news for you.
We are.
So actually, we just
announced that we'll
be raising it from 2
million to 5 million cells
We hope that that will
help further increase
the size of the files that
you're able to use today.
And we'll continue
looking at ways in order
to further expand that, as well
as making Sheets at any level
faster and more performant.
We know it's important
for you to have
Sheets that run quickly.
And so we're constantly looking
at ways to optimize that.
So the answer is yes.
2 million will become 5
million, and we're also looking
at other ways to speed it up.
Next question.
"Are there any plans
to improve charts?"
Yes.
So we've done a lot with
charts in the last year.
I mentioned the waterfall charts
and a bunch of other features
that we've added to
charts in the last year.
But we're not stopping there.
We're going to continue
to make them even better--
common requests around
customization of charts,
ability to fine tune and tweak
what's possible with charts.
One of things that
we're working on now
is actually the ability to
update individual points
or bars on individual charts.
So stay tuned for that.
That will be one
example of customization
that, hopefully, will make
charts even better for you.
Next question.
"This presentation showed
us a lot about what
you can do in Sheets today.
Where is Sheets headed
over the next year or two?"
That's a good question.
So we've been thinking a lot
about how to further improve
what's possible with analysis.
And we're thinking
a lot about how
to take advantage of, again,
data that lives elsewhere--
even especially large data
sets-- and how you can really
analyze that in Sheets.
We talked a bit about
the BigQuery integration
with Sheets.
That's in beta today.
That's just the
first of what we hope
will be several
different features
and functionality in
Sheets where you can really
do really rich and
robust analysis
on your external datasets.
So keep an eye out
for all of that.
We hope you're excited, as
we are, about all of what's
possible there.
Next question.
"What's the best approach
for transitioning from Excel
to Sheets?
Have you seen companies
do this well?"
It's a common
question that we get.
We know that many of you are
coming from the Excel world.
And so this can be a
challenge, and we admit that.
One thing we recommend
is you don't necessarily
have to do it all at once.
A lot of companies will
phase in certain segments
of their company.
So for example, maybe you start
off with marketing or sales.
It's often easier for
them to transition
immediately than those who
use longer tail functionality
in Sheets, like
the finance team.
But we really think everyone
can transition into Sheets
over time.
So it's just a matter
of them learning
where the things that they
know and love in Excel, where
that lives in Sheets.
So again, there are a lot
of common misconceptions
about-- oh, Sheets doesn't
have this function,
it doesn't pivot tables.
Well, we do.
They just have to
learn where that is.
And so there's a lot of great
help content in our Learning
Center that help provide
transition guides
and help users learn how to
make those transition more
seamlessly.
So hopefully, even your
most stubborn finance user
will hopefully find what he
or she needs to do their work
and can move over
without too much pain.
Last question.
"What's your favorite
spreadsheet function?"
So I almost said VLOOKUP.
That's a great one.
But I think actually my favorite
is probably the QUERY function.
This is one that I think
is unique to Sheets.
It's very powerful.
Actually, you can
use a type of SQL
right from within
a formula to do
some really rich
selection and filtering
and querying of your data.
So if you haven't seen
the QUERY function,
definitely encourage
you to try that out.
I think for you power
users out there,
you'll really like
what you see, I think.
And with that, I think that
concludes today's webinar.
Thanks so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]